هل الغى رونالدو ومتابعه برناردو سيلفا
بسبب ميسي ريال مدريد مهدد بخساره نقاط
مباراه خيتافي نجم انجليزي سابق مدمن على
الحبوب المنومه الممزوجه بالكحول هذه
الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم عبر قناه
العربيه رياضه واسعدوا
في اسبانيا بات ريال مدريد مهددا بخساره
نقاط مباراه خيتافي في الدوري المحلي
صحيفه اسيا الاسبانيه نشرت تقريرا اشارت
فيه الى حادثه سقوط الفرنسي
ومطالبته بمغادره الملعب نهايه اللقاء
ليتم استبداله بالفارو اوديوزول الذي ادخل
في الدقيقه الرابعه والثمانين بدلا من
اسينسيو الذي كان قد غادر الملعب ووفقا
للصحيفه فان النادي الملكي مهدد بخساره
النقاط الثلاث لمباراه خيتافي في حال
التقدم الاخير بشكوى رسميه بسبب ما حدث
قبل نهايه اللقاء
شهدت الساعات القليله الماضيه حاله من
الجدل على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي والسبب
تصريحات البرتغالي برناندو سيلفا ففي
تصريحات لصحيفه لكي بالفرنسيه اثنى لاعب
مانشستر سيتي الانجليزيه على ليونيل ميسي
ورشحه للفوز بجائزه الكره الذهبيه لافضل
لاعب لعام 2023
ليؤكد الكثيرون بعدها ان كريستيانو
رونالدو الغى متابعه سيلفا بعد تلك
التصريحات صحيفه اشارت في تقرير لها انه
بالبحث عن اسماء الاشخاص الذين يتابعهم
رونالدو عبر الانستقرام تبين فعلا ان اسم
سيلفا غير موجود الا انها شددت على انه لم
يكن معلوما ان سل ان كان سيلفا من الاشخاص
الذين يحظون بمتابعه رونالدو قبل تلك
التصريحات ام لا
والى ملعب حديقه الامراء حيث استطاع جمع
مثلث برشلونه الاسباني التاريخي بعد غياب
البرازيلي لمرضى سيلفا لاعب باريس سان
جيرمان فرنسي المصاب نشر صوره له عبر
الانستجرام وهو يتابع مباراه فريقه مع
ويظهر فيها على الهاتف مع سواريز ارفقها
بتعليق انا وسواريز نتابع معا صديقنا ميسي
تلك اللفت الانسانيه جاءت لدعم البرغوث ضد
هتافات جماهير سان جيرمان المعاديه له حيث
اطلقت الصافرات ضده قبل بدايه المباراه
للمره الثالثه خلال الموسم الحالي
في انجلترا باتا مقر نادي ارسنال يشهد
وجود رجال شرطه بشكل دائم وتحديدا داخل
ارضيه ملعب التدريب بسبب الوصوف لصوص
صحيفه اكدت ان ضباط شرطه يتواجدون في مقر
التدريب لمنع استهداف اللاعبين والتقاط
صور السياراتهم وتتبعهم عند العوده الى
منازلهم وتحر شكوك حاليا في النادي بشان
امكانيه اختباء المجرمين بين المشجعين
العاديين بهدف سرقه سيارات اللاعبين
وساعاتهم الشخصيه باهضت الثمن
الختام مع ادمان نجم سابق في الدوري
الانجليزي للحبوب المنومه الممزوجه
بالكحول صحيفه بصن اكدت ان النجم الذي لم
يكشف عن اسمه او اسم فريقه قد تم حظر
التعامل معه في الصيدليات بسبب تزويره
للفحوصات الطبيه هذه الحبوب تدعى تعالج
القلق وتساعد على النوم وليست مدرجه ضمن
العقاقير الممنوعه من وكاله مكافحه
المنشطات الدوليه الا ان مخاطرها تكمن في
الادمان وتمنح وتمنح ضمن وصفات طبيه مرفقه
بتحذير عدم خلطها او شرب الكحول قبل او
بعد تناولها
[موسيقى]